Grönlands atemberaubende Landschaften.
Doch die eigentlichen Schätze dieser
unendlich großen Insel
liegen für viele unter Eis und Schnee.
Edelsteine wie der rote Tugtupit zum Beispiel;
Ilannguaq Olsen würde gerne mit diesem
Reichtum seiner Heimat Geld verdienen –
als erster Grönländer mit einer eigenen
kleinen Mine.
Seit meiner Kindheit habe ich
davon geträumt, einen Schatz auszugraben.
Als ich dann hörte, dass in Süd-Grönland
Uran abgebaut werden sollte, wollte ich
zeigen,
dass es umweltfreundlichere Bodenschätze
gibt,
zum Beispiel solche Edelsteine.
Ob Uran, Seltene Erden oder Gold:
Angelockt vom schmelzenden Eis wollen
immer mehr ausländische Investoren
von der autonomen Regierung der Insel
Minenlizenzen.
Einheimische Inuit wie Olsen ärgert,
dass die Bodenschätze Grönlands bislang
nur von Ausländern ausgebeutet werden.
Mit der Vergabe der ersten großen
Minenlizenzen 2009 ging es los.
Dabei gibt es bis heute in Grönland
keine öffentliche Debatte darüber, was wir
eigentlich
und vor allem wie wir es aus dem Boden
holen sollen!
Die vielen Neubauten in der Hauptstadt Nuuk
können nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen:
Fast jeder fünfte Grönländer lebt unterhalb
der Armutsgrenze.
Unternehmer Olsen will darum,
dass die Gewinne aus den Bodenschätzen
im Land bleiben.
Und das meinen auch viele
seiner Landsleute:
Wir sollten von unseren Bodenschätzen
profitieren. Es ist doch unser Land.
Der Profit sollte uns gehören. Das machen
andere Länder doch genauso.
So wie hier vor zwei Jahren gehen
Grönländer immer wieder auf die Straße –
gegen die Ausbeutung der grönländischen
Bodenschätze durch Großkonzerne.
Doch für den zuständigen Minister gibt es
keine Alternative
zu den großen Investoren aus China,
Australien oder den USA.
Ein Unternehmen muss über die notwendige
Erfahrung und das Wissen verfügen,
um mit einer schwierigen Natur wie in
Grönland zurechtzukommen.
Und es muss auch das notwendige Kapital
haben, um unsere Vorgaben
erfüllen zu können.
Diese Haltung der Regierung verbittert
Ilannguaq Olsen.
Zuhause entdeckt er auf der Karte des
Ministeriums,
dass multinationalen Konzernen erneut
Gebiete
für Erkundungen zugesprochen worden sind.
Wie sollen wir gegen die ankommen?
Wir haben einfach nicht die Mittel und das
Geld,
um solche großen Minen zu betreiben.
Doch auch um ihrer beiden Kinder willen
wollen Olsen und seine Frau nicht aufgeben.
Die Frage der Bodenschätze sei schließlich
wichtig für die Zukunft Grönlands.
Denn irgendwann einmal soll Grönland
unabhängig sein.
Unsere Kinder sollen es
einfacher haben als wir.
Sie sollen in ihrem Land
selbstbestimmt leben,
selbst darüber entscheiden, was mit den
Bodenschätzen und allem anderem passiert.
Ich wünsche mir, dass sie später in einer
Gesellschaft leben,
in der sie glücklich sein können.
Auf dem Weg zur eigenen kleinen Mine will
Olsen nicht nachlassen.
Mit einer Lizenz in der Tasche, hofft er,
spätestens im nächsten Jahr loslegen zu
können.
Wir Inuit müssen uns mehr zutrauen, sagt er:
Weil wir so lange kolonialisiert worden sind,
herrscht vor allem bei der älteren Generation
immer noch die Haltung vor:
Lasst die Regierungen nur machen.
Olsen will das ändern – und selbst von den
Reichtümern seines Landes profitieren.
Wenn auch nicht um jeden Preis:
Denn wenn zum Klimawandel der Raubbau
kommt, das weiß auch er,
könnte von Grönlands atemberaubender
Schönheit
irgendwann nicht mehr viel übrig bleiben.